[موسيقى
] ولدت في الخامس عشر من آذار (مارس) 2001
، ودائمًا ما أخبرني والدي أنه في
اللحظة التي بدأت فيها المشي ، وضع مضربًا للجولف
في يدي
، وانطلق للتو من هناك ،
نشأ والدي وهو يلعب كرة القدم
ولسوء الحظ حصل  أصيب ، لذا
انتقل إلى لعبة الجولف ، بدأت ألعب
الجولف لتتعلم عن ذلك ،
لذلك عندما ولدت في جرينواي لأجعلني ألعب الجولف ، كانت
عائلتي عائلة رياضية للغاية ،
لطالما كان لدي الكثير من اللاعبين
يلعبون الجولف
مثلي  قال والدي هو
لاعب كرة قدم رائع كان إخوته
لاعبي كرة قدم رائعين ، لذا فإن
العائلة منخرطة جدًا في الرياضة
بمجرد أن تبدأ اللعب بشكل تنافسي ،
فلا يمكنك التوقف عن الفوز ، هل
كنت في الواقع أول لاعب في
التاريخ يفوز بالبطولات الكبرى للناشئين
ألقاب
في جنوب إفريقيا ، نعم ، بعد أن
لعبت أول بطولة لي ، كنت في السادسة من
عمري في
جولة أطفال جنوب إفريقيا
وبقدر ما أتذكر أنني
خرجت كنت أتنافس على الفور
وأعتقد أنني فزت
عندما كنت في
السابعة من عمري ، ومنذ ذلك الحين استمر في
التدرب على الذهاب إلى النطاق كل يوم ، أبقى
والدي نوعًا
ما ممتعًا قدر الإمكان بالنسبة لي ، لذلك كنت
لا أزال
صغيراً وفزت بأول حدث وطني لي عندما
كان عمري 11  سنة في إيستر الأولاد
تحت سن 13 عامًا
، ونعم ، لقد عدنا ، فزنا
بهؤلاء الأولاد في
سن 15 تحت 17 عامًا ثم ضعف 19 عامًا
والتي أكملت بالطبع البطولات الأربع الكبرى للناشئين ،
لذا فقد كنا ناجحين جدًا
في حلبة الناشئين.
وربما كان تتويجًا لمسيرتك المهنية الصغيرة
هو الفوز ببطولة اللاعبين الناشئين
في نفس العام
في نفس الدورة مثل روري ماكيلروي عندما
فاز في حدث جولة pga
، فهل كان مثلًا بالنسبة
لك ، نعم بالتأكيد أعني أنني فعلت ذلك
لقد تابعته لبعض الوقت
الآن ، أود أن أقول
إنه منذ دخوله إلى الحلبة
وبدأ في الفوز بالتخصصات ، وقد أحببت
للتو
كيف أنه ليس أكبر
رجل هناك ، إنه مجرد واحد من أصعب
العمال
عظيم بال  أنا مهاجم ، لذا
فقد استندت في لعبتي إلى أسلوب لعبه ،
فأنا أحب الطريقة التي يلعب بها داخل وخارج
ملعب الجولف ، ومن ثم من الواضح أن
مشاهدته يفوز ببطولة اللاعبين
التي كانت
بطولة لدي  أحببت دائمًا
المشاهدة وربما كان أحد التحديثات المفضلة لدي
هناك مع الأساتذة الذين كانوا
يراقبونه حول ذلك ومن ثم
الحصول على فرصة للذهاب
ولعب بطولة اللاعبين الناشئين
في نفس الدورة بنفس الإعداد
كان مذهلاً ثم الذهاب  كان
هناك ثمار في القمة والفوز في تلك
البطولة
كان مجرد كرز في المقدمة ، إنه
إنجاز رائع رائع ،
لقد أحببت دائمًا ضغط
المنافسة
والارتقاء في القمة ، نعم
بمجرد أن تصبح محترفًا ، أعني
مسيرتك المهنية كهاوي ، يمكنك نوعًا
ما أن تنسى أنك
تبدأ من الأسفل نوعًا ما ، لذا تشعر
أن هناك الكثير من التوقعات ولكن
عليك
فقط الاستمرار والتعلم نوعًا ما
من كل بطولة
كل  في كل لقطة تلعبها ،
لقد أحببت الضغط دائمًا كما
أحب أن أحب الوجود في اللحظات
ولكن نعم هناك بالتأكيد القليل من
الضغط لأكون هناك
وأداء ولإثبات نفسك